foreign
[Music]
today we'll talk about serverless Spark
I'm Abhishek kashyap I lead product
management for open source data
analytics at Google cloud and I'm very
excited to have Richard Williamson and
Ethan Keel from Walmart joining me today
before we talk about anything
I would really like to thank them for
taking the time the use case they will
talk about is very high impact and we
all deal with it every day
so in terms of
and talk about many many new things that
we are announcing today for dataproc and
serverless Park
then Richard and Ethan will follow up
they'll talk about the scale they deal
with at Walmart the use cases and how
they are using serverless part to solve
them
so let's start with data block
data clock is Google cloud service
for open source data analytics
at scale
providing you with the best price
performance for your workloads
we are heavily focused on security and
reliability for your open source
workloads so your customers who are the
business teams get a rock solid platform
that you have to do minimum work
managing and is at the price performance
that fits your budget
we
we provide you a single end-to-end
platform through seamless Integrations
with vertex AI for AIML as well as with
other data analytics products like
dataplex and bigquery so you don't have
to do a lot of integration work
in terms of what we focus on the focus
for data proc is four key areas
one
we want to continue providing you the
best price performance in the industry
for spark workloads
second
We Believe spark should be Cloud native
with serverless execution just like data
analysts can use SQL in a data warehouse
without worrying about VMS
spark should be the same way
third
we are going to bring spark to your data
center because a lot of customers we see
can move 90 95 percent of their data and
processing to the cloud but a small
sliver continues to stay in the data
center for very very sensitive data
and finally we are continuously
investing in Leading Edge security and
compliance
because the compliance landscape is
evolving very very rapidly
so let's start with price performance
well an analyst TST did a study and
found that
Hadoop clusters when migrated to data
block lead to a 54 lower TCO then the
Hadoop clusters on-prem so this was the
starting point they compared us with
other Cloud Solutions as well and found
the number is not 54 percent but it's
anywhere between 30 to 50 percent
because of our agent price performance
the study is about an year old
over the last year we have made
significant improvements in price
performance
if you think about data proc these are
open source analytics workloads running
on data in either Google Cloud Storage
or on bigquery storage for both of them
we have made significant improvements in
4k areas
first one is in the spark run type we
are making a lot of improvements to the
execution engine and over time
contributing them back to the open
source these are not right way
second
for bigquery storage and GCS we have
made a lot of improvements to those
bigquery and GCS are also making
significant improvements to better
better these Spark workloads
and finally gcp is continuously evolving
hardware and we are leveraging Hardware
to get the best price performance for
you
now the second area of focus which is
serverless Spark
if you look at spark today the
traditional model where you create a
cluster and then you run jobs in it IDC
found that this requires
about 60 percent of our developers time
to think about the infrastructure what
VM type do I need what shape do I need
will I interfere with others how much
capacity you need etc etc
if
if someone thinks that you're spending a
lot less than 60 percent would would
love to know more I've actually talked
with data scientist teams who say my job
was supposed to be data science but here
I am thinking about VMS I need versus
the model I need to build so with
serverless spark
we want to make this a hundred percent
time on your business logic we don't
believe data engineers and data
scientists should be spending so much
time on infrastructure management and
sizing we want you to focus on your
spark application
and provide you with a serverless
service where you submit your
application it runs you don't worry
about it and you only pay for the time
the job is going you are not buying
infrastructure anymore you are not
paying for startup time shutdown times
you're just having long underutilized
clusters you treat spark as an API that
will run your application
and architecture-wise that's how it is
built serverless power is an API you
submit your code to it
it will start off auto scale using smart
Dynamic allocation there is no yawn
it will scale back down all the
resources will be cleaned up after your
job is done executing
and we have also made
significant improvements tools by Auto
scaling and contributed it back to the
community and
this is now much much better than
yarn-based Auto scale
since this is an API you can connect
from your interface of choice be it
bigquery be it a notebook be it an
orchestration platform like airflow or
composer and it will connect to any
auxiliary service you can have data
block metastore you could have a hive
meta store in your own data center you
can connect to any of those and this
does work
on different file formats table formats
to a optimized GCS connectors or with
bigquery storage as well
foreign
slide has an issue
all the logos went off okay
that's right so
what are we announcing today
the key announcement today is for spark
for interactive development for data
science
the first one is what you might have
already heard in the keynote serverless
file now supports Nvidia gpus
we are starting with L4 and a100 gpus so
for a subsidy of your workloads you can
get up to a 10x speed up
we are the first serverless service to
add support for this for spark and we'll
continue making it better
if development is that just like for
batch workload you could just submit to
an API you can now start an on-demand
spark development session the
traditional way where you keep a cluster
up and running you access its notebook
even if it's 20 utilized at night you
cannot shut it down you no longer need
to do that your your data scientist data
engineer can log in through a notebook
click a button start an on-demand
session it will auto scale with an idle
time to live it will be cleaned up after
the user is done so you don't have to do
cost management you don't have all these
resources sitting idle and users get
fully isolated environments for their
notebooks so you don't even run into
issues of one user's code
making the cluster out of memory so you
get a much higher reliability as well
interactive sessions are available to a
full
key interfaces one we have open sourced
a jupyter plugin so you can go to the
marketplace and install a jupyter plugin
to any jupyter Notebook on your laptop
in the cloud and start working with
serverless spark from right there second
vertex AI has managed notebooks you can
access them from there and very soon we
are going to be on two partner notebooks
as well one being hacks and the second
being deep knot so you can go there and
you serve on the spark as well
okay so here's a quick demo this is this
is a user on their laptop they're just
launching Jupiter lab
you get to Jupiter lab you can see a
list of data clusters you can connect to
or you can start an on-demand serverless
spark session you can Define templates
for the users to use it will create
infrastructure in the back end on demand
you can start a notebook start coding
against it you are on your local Jupiter
but each cell is being executed on this
highly parallel infrastructure that auto
scales based on spark Dynamic allocation
in this example we are analyzing some
weather data
once the user is done
the this is all cleaned up with the
title as I mentioned and you can work
with python SQL scholar and R through
these sessions
so this is available in public preview
today will be GA in about a month so you
can go try this out
foreign
platform the most common one we see is
airflow we are managed air flow Services
composer today we are announcing a step
change in how composer is used we are
announcing serverless composer
you
so far you had to worry about a lot of
pieces a lot of IP addresses to use
composer with serverless composer we
launch everything in attendant project
spin up all the services that composer
needs behind the scenes you don't have
to worry about it so your users can just
focus on that ads we take care of
managing airflow for you managing all
the services needed for you to run this
reliable orchestration service
and you get features like this will
connect to your VPC with a single click
there is no need to use a range of ips
anymore it will use a maximum of two
internal IPS so with serverless composer
this will make your orchestration
pipelines a lot easier to manage
foreign
[Applause]
some of you may be aware we have an
anthos based Appliance called Google
distributed cloud
the idea is that if you have certain
workloads that need to stay in your data
center then this gives you uh
an environment so you can standardize
Services across gcp and your data center
so you don't have to maintain two
separate stacks and operate them now
this has been available generally
available what we are announcing today
is the availability of spark through
data proc on GDC Edge
so let's say you have sensitive data
that cannot leave your data center
you start using Cloud for 95 percent of
your data processing you can use the
same spark applications deploy it on GDC
Edge in your own Data Center and have
very low operational costs in managing
spark across two environments such as
gcp and your data center now this this
is a full stack it comes with all the
auxiliary Services you need like gcpim
or logging monitoring so you can just
install it and start using spark the
same way as you do on cloud this is
available in private preview and you can
talk to your sales rep if you are
interested
[Applause]
a quick view on security and reliability
I know this is not something that sounds
very cool but this is very very
important for a lot of our customers we
have very very Advanced security
features like
encryption using your keys but using an
external key manager and requiring
access justification for key access
similarly you can control who supports
you who sees your logs you can enforce
our policies that encryption Keys must
be used and you can connect to your own
ID like active directory versus using
gcpin and finally for data residency we
now support it at West in transit and in
use so data block is now available to be
used in a lot of places where compliance
requirements are very high
the next announcement we have is that
dataplex which is our governance
platform now supports table level
lineage for spark as well
so if you use multiple gcp Services you
can go to dataplex and see lineage for
bigquery for data flow and now Spark so
you have a single place where you can
see all lineage and this works not just
for SQL but for spark in other languages
as well
and
so yeah I have to go really fast to give
all the time to Walmart so we are happy
to talk about these offline
if you deal with stockouts we have a new
feature for data block where you can
Define multiple VM shapes
and when we create a data cluster or
Auto scale it we'll pick the best one
based on availability
so in peak times when sometimes these
operations may have caused reliability
issues with flexible VMS you will be
able to get a much will more reliable
firms to give you an example let's say
you wanted High memory machines but Ram
was in shortage you also provide us with
a shape with smaller Ram we will use
that shape and make it happen for you
this this is available in public preview
you can start using it today as well
and the last one
last one metastore which we
are announcing to be available
for active active disaster recovery so
you can now deploy date of birth meta
store in multiple regions in an active
active configuration
it will sustain a regional outage
because metadata is critical your
applications will continue running it
comes with horizontal scaling so without
any downtime you can scale it up and
down depending on your workload and it
supports fine grained access control so
rather than having many many meta stores
you can have a single one and you can
control access among your users and
business units
and with that I would like to invite
Richard to kick it off for Walmart thank
you Richard
[Applause]
thank you Abby it's been a pleasure
working with you and your team over the
last couple of years to scale out Apache
spark for Walmart's use cases
and great to see everyone here I lead
the applied AI end to end machine
learning engineering team for Walmart
we support over 100 data scientists
running lots of models on Apache spark
for us
I started with Walmart in 96 as part of
the first AI team within Walmart so I've
seen lots of growth in the AI space over
the years
the first half of my career was spent as
a data scientist writing optimization
and forecasting models
and then in 2009 I shifted Focus to
build out the first Hadoop clusters at
Walmart and since then I've been helping
data scientists scale their machine
learning problems ever since
So today we're going to talk about
serverless architecture for API driven
workflows
but first just a bit about Walmart
as our customers shopping patterns have
changed we've been quickly adapting to
help serve our customers better
we understand now that our customers
time is more valuable than ever so we've
introduced things like online pickup and
delivery within our stores and scanning
at Sam's so you can walk right out with
the without going to a register
so these are just a few of the ways
we've been enabling our customers to
save time
with the tremendous business scale that
we have at Walmart which you can see
from this slide we obviously have to
build uh technology platforms at massive
scale
our team currently focuses on Walmart us
which has over 5000 stores with a broad
item selection so you can quickly see
how the scale matters
[Music]
open source platforms like Apache spark
and Apache Hadoop have helped us
mitigate vendor lock-in for over a
decade now
that's allowed our business to scale for
these needs
we now run concurrent models using
hundreds of thousands of course and we
work with tables up to 100 trillion rows
that's 18 petabytes in a single table
our area is platform of choice for this
massive scale is Apache spark and we
have leveraged gcp spark serverless over
the last two years since it was in
preview mode
I've been very thankful to obby's team
we actually went to production right as
it went to GA with with our first use
case and we've had no downtime from it
our architecture Team Works across Five
mlor Pillars supporting various business
domains from supply chain to Merchant
merchandising
and we built this end-to-end model
serving solution
we've been teaching our data scientists
to start using pi Spark versus python uh
right from the get-go so they don't have
to translate later
we use the flexible architecture
template which you can see here our
infrastructure supports now near
real-time or models which do not follow
the typical model training and inference
structure
so each model is computed dynamically
and results are obtained at the end of
The Run
so if you look at the diagram here
you'll see the application API we'll
call our integration API Hub and then
from there we'll pick the specific
plug-in those plugins will kick off a
spark serverless job and return the
results back to the business
the serverless architecture has allowed
us instead of relying on the one cluster
mini jobs problem of having contention
across those jobs
to now just have a single scalable
platform in two Dimensions so basically
we can scale the number of concurrent
jobs easily and for each job we can
scale out to thousands of course per job
[Music]
and then here's how we think about our
mle development life cycle so as you saw
from from Bobby's slide on the
interactive sessions we've been using
some of those in preview so some of our
data scientists will go use those
sessions others will be working on a
local Jupiter notebook the key obviously
is to give them a clean slate where they
can start
developing without having lots of
constraints from from Tech
um and then within there they'll build
out their data frames from either csvs
or bigquery and then once they're ready
to move to production we will help them
within our environment to scale those
algorithms to Pi smart using things like
the pandas UDF
and I think this architecture will make
a lot more sense if I turn it over to
our team member Ethan Keel to show a use
case
[Music]
hello everyone my name is Ethan Keel and
I'm a senior data scientist on Richard's
applied AI architecture team I've been
with Walmart for the past two years and
in that time we've seen our ml Ops and
mle pipelines grow exponentially
and today I want to help show how
serverless spark was able to drive that
growth
I have the great privilege to talk about
one of our Flagship algorithms that I
have worked on for the past two years
called store assortment optimization it
recently won the informs prize for uh
operations excellence
and from a business perspective it is a
tool that delivers a locally optimized
space aware assortment recommendation
and what that means is we are actually
optimizing the number and type of items
in a store based on merchandising
information and forecast data
you can imagine how this is critical to
Walmart's mission of serving our
customers the items they want
at the price they deserve so they can
live better
specifically where store Summit
assortment optimization is used is with
our merchants and they usually use three
adjectives to describe his algorithm
fast transparent and strategic
it is fast it has to be able to deliver
an assortment recommendation in less
than an hour transparent we have to be
able to show how our current stores
Optima our our current stores assortment
compares to our optimized assortment
and strategic
on top of all this it has to be able to
adhere to business and Supply supply
chain constraints
on the diagram on the right you can see
how Merchants think about implementing a
new assortment with this tool
going from inputting your data and then
just seeing an optimized assortment and
then comparing afterwards and under the
hood you can see we are using forecasts
and calculating incrementality which is
the uniqueness of an item applying
constraints and then running our model
now here comes the overwhelming part
to highlight just how overwhelming some
of these slas were I decided to just put
a ton of words on this slide and try to
enforce you to read them in a minute 30
or less
um
so from our perspective a store
assortment optimization is a batch
operations research Optimizer what that
means is we are using a batch of stores
and we're trying to calculate the
assortment for every store individually
it has to be able to scale to 4 600
stores
and a hundred thousand items per store
run under one hour support up to 100
simultaneous requests
and all the while minimize our costs
you can imagine how much my colleagues
on ours were sweating when we uh when we
read this
um but
really serverless spark saved us quite a
bit here it enabled us to stick to our
principles of everyday low prices
deliver that time optimized result
deliver persistent results with the
bigquery connector
and the GCS connector and then it is
scalable in two Dimensions one from a
model level where we are able to
scale one run to All 4 600 stores and
then two enable a high throughput of
requests at the same time
foreign
so as Richard was talking about
integration Hub
um you know we really framed that idea
around a clean architecture plug-in
adapter type architecture
but it also adheres to uh Michael
Scott's keep it simple stupid
methodology and I'll show you how it
does that
starting at the bottom left corner we
are getting a request from our business
partners for an optimization
this request contains details of what we
want optimized and all of the
merchandising data we may need
that request then goes to our service
mesh layer called integration Hub that
is built in-house and
which routes the request to the correct
plugin
that plug-in logic then uses our
Merchant information to dynamically set
the pi spark configurations
required and able to meet all of our
slas
once we finish once that plug-in
dynamically sets those configurations it
posts that information up to our first
feature store which contains our
Merchant metadata our PI spark
configurations and the third thing I
haven't talked about yet are model
repository integration Hub does not
actually post the repository the data
science team in our CI CD pipelines are
responsible for that but it is
nonetheless included in our input
feature store
once our metadata is pushed up to that
GCS bucket
integration Hub then sends a restful
request to the serverless dataproc
batches API with the metadata URL
required for that run
and I'll go a little bit more into
detail about what's actually happening
in this component in the next slide but
for now you can kind of think about it
as both an ETL Pipeline and our model
server in pipeline
finally when our model finishes it posts
all of our pre-processed data our output
data and then enables our end users to
look at dashboard views of our results
and
decide if they want to use that
assortment
data scientists often also use this
information for that cicd Pipeline and
to identify anything that may have gone
wrong in the Run
so now I'm digging a little deeper into
that serverless dataproc component
uh serverless the the badge itself can
be thought of as an individual component
of a model serving pipeline
or as the entire end-to-end serving
infrastructure
the diagram on the right illustrates how
this is possible
in the topmost layer we have our
pre-processing data ETL
so this is a pipeline that leverages Pi
Sparks scalability and distribution to
most efficiently
perform our ETL functions
now the second layer is where it gets a
little bit more interesting that second
layer can go one of two ways we can
either use the right pathway which uh
leverages the exact same Pi spark
configurations as that first ETL
pipeline or on the left side we can
actually trigger a new batch that has
new Pi spark configurations and enables
us to maybe build bigger models that
could not use the same Pi spark
configurations as a typical ETL pipeline
one example of this is going from having
a CPU handle one task
to having 16 CPUs handle one task for
one model
and then that third layer is exactly the
same as that pre-processing layer the
only thing different again here is
whether or not it is using the pi spark
configurations from that previous layer
this architecture has enabled us to host
a wide variety of operations research
models scaling from 100 000 variables
all the way up to 13.5 million which is
a huge feat considering this all needs
to be done under an hour
one amazing component about serverless
spark is its horizontal scalability
that enables us to get that time
efficiency and that cost efficiency
component that Walmart really needs in
order to operate efficiently
for one job we can see a range of two to
six thousand CPUs being dynamically
scaled based on the various requirements
that integration Hub has provided for
that job
so now I would like to go into you know
some of the benefits that we have
received from transitioning to this
model serving infrastructure some
immediate benefits cost savings huge we
were able to radically change our cost
model for serving operations research
models
the second one infrastructure
reliability we with a static approach we
often faced lots of downtime having to
maintain our clusters and just really
we're not able to keep a 24 hour
reliability that we that our Merchants
thought
[Applause]
and then fourth
an increased request throughput in our
previous architecture the static
dataproc clustered architecture we were
only able to serve about 12 models at a
time
we have now increased that to about 100
models simultaneously
some benefits that were realized over
time one of my favorite reduced carbon
output the ephemeral nature of these
clusters really has enabled us to be
more conscious of how we are using our
servers
the second one supercharged Spark
again that ephemeral nature is huge in
being able to transition our PI spark
configurations for to use more disk and
less RAM for super heavy uh memory
operations for example we once had a
greedy algorithm that had you know 50
window operations 50 Group by statements
and we were running out of memory every
single job and as soon as we were able
to start using that checkpoint with
serverless spark everything started
working and that's really difficult to
use with the static cluster
third eliminated on-call infrastructure
support huge
I can't tell you how many more hours of
sleep I've gained
and finally the scalability of our
continuous uh integration and
Improvement pipeline
with the development of our interactive
sessions uh thanks to ABI we have been
able to radically change how we think
about actually developing large-scale
models and ETL pipelines and it
integrates seamlessly with the actual
serverless data proc batches
so what's next for dataproc at Walmart
we really are excited to Leverage The
GPU accelerators on serverless dataproc
this will help a ton both in our PI
spark operations but also if we ever
migrated our models to using some of the
pi spark native languages
second standardizing this serverless
architecture as we have built out
integration Hub and store assortment
optimization was really our first use
case we've onboarded you know about a
dozen new models onto the same
architecture but we've got dozens more
to go
and then third applying spark lens
insights into
how we think about
our PI spark configurations it's really
useful for setting a correct Dynamic
allocation ratio or for determining the
maximum number of executors for your SLA
at the end of the day like I said it's
all like from an ml Ops perspective it's
all about the slas and so having that
information is always helpful
and finally our applied architecture
team is hiring please uh yeah please
reach out if you're interested
um and I would like to invite my my
fellow speakers back on stage uh your
feedback is greatly appreciated thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]